For example, here is a brief description of a family called the pipe and
filter family, which you should now be familiar with.
There's a type of component, not a component but a type of component,
called the filter type. Another type of component called the pipe type. And
we might then use. This, this additional vocabulary in defining a system. And
you notice that in the declaration of the system, there's a type given to it.
In this case, it's the PipeAndFiltersFamily. And
we're now going to define specific components that correspond to
the types we've defined in the family description. So filter 1 is a, a type,
filter type and likewise is filter 2 and then connector is of the pipe type.